next game um black against
2200 player
kevin king from spain
i don't think i played them okay we got
a classic classical rule lopez here
and it's going for d4 instead of the
usual h3 line
d4 is a pretty interesting alternative
all right queen c7 i need to play queen
c7 here
yeah i need to retreat the bishop to c8m
this was just um a little bit too
too quickly moved
hmm
to h5 it's not not the square i want to
go to
okay let's take this it's a bit ugly
i am stupid i need to go to c7 of course
not quite sure why i went to c8
i really miss um the light squared
bishop
so it's the most important piece
actually for black
to cover the light square weakness on d5
okay this is very very very bad already
he has got ideas to bring the knight to
f5 and bishop g5 and so on
okay i'm glad to exchange this this was
a mistake most likely
nothing completely terrible but um
i'm glad to to get rid of the knight
which
would have been awful on f5
yeah h6 was designed to prevent bishop
g5
i tried to exchange bishop d8b6 if i
manage this i'm
i'm ok again
yeah i've got white of course white is
still
somewhat better with these two bishops
yeah also logical move
one issue here could be queen g3
threatening on h6
but maybe i can i can even answer this
with
king f8 simply
i don't think i can i could i could take
on e4 because he's got
strange moves like maybe queen g6
queen g3 and takes on e4 queen g6 or
wit moves i don't know
um okay if i play bishop to b6
now we can take on h6
ugly
yeah i cannot play bishop b6 and then
it's uh it's a problem
how to improve the position without this
idea
maybe b4
yeah uncomfortable
if it takes now rook takes okay it works
as my pawn structure
but maybe i have some ideas on e4
g4 wow
yeah this is very direct h4 g5 and uh
killing me on f7 so not without its
logic
okay capture that first
now i'm trying to figure out
how dangerous this really is
yeah maybe
maybe even this one on h4 i can play
knight h7
it's very passive or all that but what
can you do
yeah the position really got bad right
of the opening after this queen c8 i
thought i
had improved a bit but it's still bad
yeah now this terrible terrible ugly
ugly looking move g5
this is really ugly chess
yeah it looks terrible
do
yeah yeah i would like to go here but
i also need to attend g5
okay now g5 is protected
and the position here is is quite closed
maybe i can even get this in this bishop
maneuver
yeah he wants to play morning we should
bishop a4
okay what about the move like d5 here
to open it up maybe getting some counter
play come on
can't sit here all day
and i wanted to play e4 but he's got d6
i can take on f3 then
try to mix it up here with the time
getting down
his king is not this not very safe
okay can capture with the knight now
threatening also on h2 maybe
looks dangerous for white
check
check check
threatening a discovery i need to get
the rook brook
to play check
rook to f4 would be nice
check
check checkmate
yeah i tricked him with the time time
getting down and
uh opening up his skin position it
certainly wasn't wasn't the most correct
way to play maybe
even stuff hanging here but well
this at least opened up his king
maybe it's entirely rubbish but yeah of
course the computer wants to take with
the bishop but
i wasn't so so afraid of this i can
play a bit on the dark squares then
knight c7 a 97 c5 and so on
and yeah maybe he can play a computer
actually gives d6 here
yeah it was a gamble with time getting
getting down
and and this is already equal
but uh i guess not after this yeah now
i'm getting
getting strong play okay rook f1 is the
draw
yeah but it doesn't really matter this
is just uh
just the time scramble our queen g3 is
made made next move
almost next move yeah i didn't have much
time
yeah i was maybe quite good at the end
from practical point of view but uh
of course this is just bad i need to go
to c7
here and on h3 i retreat all the way
back to
c8 this is uh this is better and then i
can
use the bishop on b7 or maybe later on
e6
when it is secure on e6 and now i only
have
the choice between things i don't want
to play bishop h5 is also not great
because i need to exchange it anyway
later or i would go to g6 at some point
where it is also misplaced so this is
just uh just bad
and um yeah here i'm just just playing
um
an inferior position okay next game